we're doing a report on the situation
of roma in france
you know we're not married i'm
from the south of france and i come here and
it's a man all we see
why because i shouldn't have
existed that  a marvelous capital
like france like paris to see all
these people here this awful it's a
shame
what bothers you it bothers me
who are robbed in heart and
that I don't tolerate the problem of
roma camps which are not very not very
clean after probably
showing them in the evening honestly me i
think there are some it's not too much but
they settle badly stalin slums
me i ask myself the second my hut
logically  it's not correct what
is first of all a little bit nobis so they
bring in several people at the same
time it takes noises of what and
how also I see them treating their
children why why not go to
work like everyone else who is
there  and increasingly better educated  er their
children romania is a
is the country of the european union where he
can return without a visa and that's the
problem
me i have a negative image of the roma for
example why example style there he does
n't work you have to ask mendy
money from passers-by and
tourists and all that is not they
steal if it is sealed the metros the games
and stigmatizes the roma so much it's
not good we have to be careful with these
things he steals fire extinguisher inevitably it
affects us  since everyone says it well
we too in the end we say to ourselves ah yes
we have to be careful
so that's it so stop what in fact
what people think I think they
play they are afraid in fact they are afraid
they judge a lot  in fact it founds a
case a generality